don't forget there's equations okay so
like if you want to push straight by
you're going to need a lot more you can
always take
off got it so play with it a little more
that way okay don't let
yourself start to tense up you can take
off whatever
yes okay that is the TR
yes
that's
turn
so as you go you have this hand right
you feel that keep the other hand
going two
together you do that or you can cut this
one closer
see you cut this closer and that one
have more you see that so you tend to
let it go dead once you do that you stop
and then this hand you you do that hand
okay yes
that's so that one both hands to
okay see how much you
okay
without that was your
one more
so why that one was good is you're not
forcing
that you find where it can come in
without you doing
that here see close it you see that but
it's light light
boom not
nice
nice see how it feels like nothing but
look where I'm going okay should feel
like nothing
[Music]
so see by not trying not to be strong
you're strong now okay you'll always
want to stay here and go that way
don't yes
that was
good good yeah that's the
[Music]
voice much right so let's say you start
on you come here and you feel the
weight you see that you can always move
it you see so you'll feel the
the pressure to much look at mov okay so
it would be
seamless
see yes
feel like
I'm this way you're bringing it that
don't judge it there's no there's no
right there's no right okay there's no
right there's just a
feeling careful cuz that judging mind is
the same pushing mind feel the
feel the
nothingness you get it and again you
just feel the
nothingness don't judge
it don't get
bored right there's no there's no rest
it's just this moment yes
doesn't matter
right you judge you judge you have right
here it's right there yes don't judge
you picked didn't show up and then you
got stop juding don't
pick feel
feel let
[Music]
happen you're doing great right don't
judge don't get bed
is that you're bre
let's do no gra don't let them Gra
you try I
don't want to do no different yes
yes if they gra they get it as
money one more
get of the both
seem attached to the
up so let's look at the up you kind of
go like
up but I'm more when I
touch it it itself I aim past your foot
you see that's what gives you the sense
of up it's not me
going so even on this one I'm not going
up I just go past the
foot if you lose your balance you you're
making up you see
that use it it don't let
it so you see it's not up just past your
basic support
watch this one now don't use
this just
here
okay
[Music]
don't yeah just use it trust it TR it
trust it trust it don't
it yes yes yes yes yes keep
them yes yep you don't it doesn't have
to go down so far
back so what you're feeling you feel
pressure there but you think it's from
not and it's from keep
going when you catch up to it like go
that way say I got off so when you catch
up to it I move it this way
see just turn take it 90° to what it's
doing so not here I know it feels like
that but it's not that it's going this
way that
way I keep l
go this way no just take it yes that's
all you need to go don't
hook yes protect
pass yes yes yes yes
don't don't pick it's all right there
find
it yes
you you can't mess up it's not possible
till the discriminating
mind okay
and as you move take sh see
shift same move
arms shift
weight
okay sh Shi yes yes
yes now as you're doing that let your
arms release more and accept
more yes
than you feel it not the
arm
yes don't
judge don't forget the tip on don't go
up
then here qu as I move you see qu
turns you
see
is see Shi
the
okay but no
arms sh
watch your arms don't turn arms stay
still CLW
turn think of like
uh uh
hole so you're right here so you move
out so I
don't quago here
remember see okay right here not
here here okay so in your mind picture
that c you hole C you hole with the core
there no
arms all qu arms Bo quaw too much
waist don't don't try for the
effect to much
was
is just so if you look the
quaw goes to
here quaw knee foot not past it
okay
qu too much too much Center KN foot too
much just a tiny
bit yes yes yes yes yes it's very small
if you want to try to throw hard you're
going to overdo it it's very
small good that was good not you were
trying for one thing and the other thing
happen didn't
[Music]
yes there
is feels like nothing right
yeah don't let other hand sh off
okay so you have power right now
relax he
this is
a
b see
a okay got it so they feel different so
I'll just do B
B still
go just be
okay trust
it when you feel the Earth to tense
release
again
yep little
tense yep yeah
one more like
that
yes
okay and T in
turn this field with your hands this is
who knows it we get here but my
hands with the inward hour spiral you
see
they're making the T turn move
[Music]
jaw turn your
down everything quad I shifted Paw's
going to weight's going to shift you
see I turn the T and when I shift
T turn the T down
which makes it more wrong to go up
okay this what I want you to do for this
show is keep your hands in relation to
each other not opposite which happens
when we don't do the inward out spirals
they will go opposite but you do you do
an outward spiral on an inward spiral
you see my hands
you go one two you're doing this they go
opposite and they
lose the two hands on the on the field
okay keep them in a
relationship yes
yes trust it don't don't try to figure
it out just keep your hands your l b
facing each other in the
circles back in your CLA shift your
weight mind rotating with your hands
yes and don't forget at the
end the end is like the the EO pin
okay not big though don't go
big here I go and then you're going to
feel that
movement feel
okay all each other
there we go
small go
yes now you're not mov
[Music]
your there's still a timing you can't
let it get away from you can't let your
ball get way out here
yes yes
good release on the right hand then let
it pull
you hey don't forget shouldn't feel
strong good job okay
okay